hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play cry fear memories now we have
another chapter I'm getting what the oh
that's right oh yeah there were hoodies
I never noticed the place in the
original campaign to actually try them
on I might as well get some extra color
in here some red look at that yours
either right right there are anyway
Hinda oh yeah yeah that's us that was
not a box I was a shotgun you can't fool
me
I know the difference between a box and
gun ooh there's another bicycle that I
can't use any of you remember Sophie
Hyman let me go I revolve I love
yourself you have to leave please I
[ __ ] Walter let me go Simon
ah Simon Simon Simon Simon has trouble
with the ladies hello half lat
oh hello I can't read that escaped
suicide suicide no that's suicide
suicide that's a bunch of suicide what
do you think put your God probably a car
no a bow-wow booyakasha okay apparently
that's not chair Wow all right so that
was freaky oh this is actually the room
where has the ceiling gone ah whoa oh no
oh oh no those guys look like mannequins
huh oh it's like Oh Senate shivers up my
spine I swear
okay getting out of there oh it's freaky
I wonder if I go back in this one it'll
be the same okay it's the same okay
alright we're okay the key there Wow oh
okay
fetch oh oh no oh no oh no oh no oh I
see something down there the door [ __ ]
I'll have an ammo and anything arrived
summer oh boy
Oh can you guys hear that
it's like a fan or a heartbeat
Oh
oh I'm like hearing things off to the
left and right oh oh
who's the door oh oh
[Music]
I can think of nothing witty to say at
the moment I am focused on the task at
hand oh man oh man you know you get used
to something in amnesia for so long you
forget that other games I have to dock
it open okay you forget that other games
can really really [ __ ] with you wait I
hear something behind that wall
I hear something behind that wall I
really do but ah hello that's nice
always check the top job oh yeah ah I
see you there's a key
oh that's Sophie I just I picked up the
syringe eh
Oh a dive room Oh God the chainsaw man
doesn't even call blood oh yeah that's
another um
[Music]
oh that's another mod that they've made
they made that one for Resident Evil I'm
sure it was good but I don't have risen
you play it on ah okay all right okay
they save oh this look good you're my
leg to it yeah
oh-oh-oh-oh
seriously my leg jerked up into the tip
oh god I want out I want out oh ah oh I
am bulletproof oh it's great for you
buddy
that's fantastic oh oh I need a breather
oh wow okay I'm okay okay
is it chair oh okay all right
all right jump on this I jump on this
and I UMP up here and I'm okay all right
all right huh oh man
ah I should have known something was
coming I just didn't know it'd be like
that okay I'm okay
Hey hi hi hi what's up with you
huh Dumbo
say wha good yeah swamp girl you don't
want a little bump
you fat y'all you got man boobies
you feel ugly l won't ya you wanna do
I guess you don't go there haha yeah
right okay
so what do I do oh hi Shay ah yeah Thank
You fun flip bullets
I will switch to Vista now aho what God
you see you the head hand yeah
water on sir well someone had to do
sewer level I suppose all that I want to
go left
oh wait there's no way to go oh I'm
ignoring you I'm ignoring you was that
lantern rocker guy here I don't care go
away Wow hello hi there
ah hi ignoring ignoring saving huh not
him anything with him maybe if I kill
him ah I don't like this one I don't
like any of these oh yeah
Stefano ha ha ha what the [ __ ] beautiful
ah another PewDiePie reference another
beauty hi oh it's actually what you can
take
ah
Oh God
I'm not ready for that
aah oh [ __ ] you
I should've expected that oh man
you again got an IV going in that room I
don't think I don't know if you need
that oh man oh man Stefan Oh what the
[ __ ] beauty pie no no no no no no no no
back off hey butter
are you doing kill dad aha you got to
what do
Wow cry yeah man
Dominic Jojo what's the point of coming
up here oh man okay I'm out of animal on
that one
I don't know I think they just did that
because I think PD fight like scary
stefano around with them Oh Oh what do I
go you're right behind the door ah
I hear him
I do not see him
ah come on oh oh I tried to jump I tried
to jump but thank you are anyway I'm all
out of time for this episode so thank
you all so much for watching and as
always there you in the next video bye
bye